I think our new guest is gonna be
talking about plums a lot then we have
somebody who's so integral to the st.
Louis chest the Tracey O'Brien from
icterus and Arcturus is a company that
really helped st. Louis chess club form
their global identity she is with Maryse
and we love her well let's hope that she
doesn't say to me I like plums asking
stupid questions but Tracey O'Brien with
Arcturus Tracey welcome to the show
thank you tell us about our Tauruses
relationship to this Chess Club
of course this beautiful design of this
club well we were fortunate enough to
start with the Chess Club when it first
got off the ground and they first
approached us about the brand and really
kind of creating what the brand of the
the Future Chess Club would be and that
was an exciting challenge because really
it was how do you bring a fresh modern
look to a very classic game and so you
know our group between our graphic
designers architects and interior
designers we're really how do we bring
that throughout the club and some
historic buildings that that really were
not functioning as public space before
you also were a part of the state of the
world chess Hall of Fame and as well and
that's a lovely space that actually it
was even a greater challenge as it's a
landmark building and a former from the
late 1800s pharmacy and so we in terms
of structural things that we could do we
were very limited and creating a space
that also is environmentally sensitive
to art that was going to be displayed
there that that that really was a
challenge for all of us I'm thinking
about that in terms it's not every day
that an architectural firm somebody
comes to you and says we're doing a
chess club a World Chess Hall of Fame
right wait a minute it's not an office
building or just a residential home but
a chess club that must have been
something fascinating the first day it
was proposed it is and and I mean I can
say as far as I know in the u.s. no one
else has had that privilege and you know
such an asset for st. Louis
I think you know if people are still
learning about it I just met a woman
chess player the other day that I've
known for years and had no idea she
played chess and we were talking about
it and I'm like oh my gosh I have to
take you over to the club and so I'm
hoping we will have a future chess match
here and continue to build the interests
of the Chess Club and you know what it
is doing for the community and and
basically for st. Louis's our image
nationally and worldwide and so you
sound like you have that art towards had
some pride in knowing that you design
the capital of chess yes in the capital
of chess in America you know we do to be
a part of it in an ongoing part of it I
mean we're kind of on call for whatever
the club may need and whether it was
when these studios were first built out
which the initial club didn't have to
the kingside diner to a lot of the
graphics the website and sometimes I'm
supporting currently the the chest
graphics for future tournaments so we'd
love what we do and it's really it's
really been an honor to be a part of it
it shows is we are proud that you make
us all look good you do other things
though our tours are you mentioned
international nationally internationally
some of your more interesting projects
sure so well just recently here in st.
Louis we have been doing work for a
financial corporation as over two
million square feet and we just
completed a work cafe so it's a
continuous operating space it serves a
thousand people a day and it has they
grow their own greens and herbs there
and they have war rooms private dining
as well as a giant media wall beautiful
stuff indeed now I heard you say that
you played chess against your son yes
and I he beat me I will say but we had
kind of a three-year early and in his
lifetime while trying to teach him chess
I would engage with him but probably
within the year
he was definitely beating me so I'm I
now I am an empty-nester so I am hoping
to up my game and learn a little bit
more so you mean I can't ask you about
the opening moves here and the top
players in the competition and all that
I think I'm gonna leave that to you
Maurice yeah yeah I actually usually
leave it to ya Zamir
but thank you very much for being on the
show we look forward to seeing you more
oft in the club and playing those games
and use your friends thank you
Thank You Tracy O'Brien with our
tourists it's why we look as good as we
look there and people behind the scenes
Tracy I just wanted to let you know that
we have ladies night classes here at the
Chess Club on Thursday night so look for
me to be here yeah YG's and you can
bring your friends it's really an
awesome way to get more women playing
the game and you have good luck thank
you and Thank You Tracy seriously as a
chess player having traveled all over
the world engaged in many many many
chess club's it's always nice to come
back to st. Louis in this facility I
think it's beautiful
you did guys did a great job like really
a great job